since it's thursday we all know what
that means it's time to recap
last night's episode of survivor
yes and this two-hour episode was
unbelievably chaotic especially after a
familiar twist was brought back to shake
up the game
roxroy has the power to leave things
exactly as they are
whatever happened happened u6 are safe
you don't have to compete
or
roxroy has the power to go back in time
and change history by reversing the
outcome of the challenge
which means
the six of you would lose your buff
because you're not part of the merged
tribe and you six would have to compete
and fight for immunity u5 and roxroy
would be safe and would not have to
compete
huge stakes
what decision did you make
so if i smash it
six people get a do-over
but i leave it on its side
[Music]
nothing happens
sometimes everyone deserves a do-over
and now we're joined with our special
survivor correspondent and season 41
winner erica kasupanin who may just know
a thing or two about smashing that
hourglass hey erica
hi morgan hey roz yeah i may know a
little something about that
listen we have to get into all of that
and so much more but the one thing we do
have to mention is the little shout out
that jeff probst gave you last night
during the episode how did that make you
feel
i mean my bestie jeff probst still
mentions me and i'm not even on the
season so how can you not be over the
moon
that's such a fun surprise all right so
walk us through roxroy's time on exile
island um how do you feel like it
compared to your experience last season
i feel like there was a lot that was the
same about roxroy's time in that you
know you still have to live there
the people the other people still need
to earn their way to the merge but this
time they got a warning saying that
whoever goes to exile gets some power if
you win you have the chance to go to
exile and get some power so i think
because of that everybody is kind of
approaching it in a more measured way
knowing that just because you won
it doesn't mean that you're safe and
just because roxroy is gone it doesn't
mean that he's going to come back with
nothing i think that now everybody is a
bit more calculated and a bit more
measured about the morning
so break this down for people
who
can't just fathom what that would be
like like what is it like being solo on
exile island for two days and two nights
like what's going on in your head like
what's that experience actually like
all i did was eat crabs and cry
sometimes cry in the rain
[Laughter]
and i do not camp i do not camp i was
not fit to be on exile by myself but i
still managed to find food
feed myself managed to live so i think
that it was such a low moment for me
where i'm thinking what the hell am i
doing but then coming out of it i not
only get this amazing power in the game
but then i realized oh my gosh i'm
capable of something too like maybe
everybody needs to go to egg style and
grow a little once in their lifetime
yeah i love that crabs and crying all
right now you've obviously been in rocks
roy's shoes but what was it like being
able to actually watch his experience on
fold on tv
from a selfish point of view it it
actually made me a little nostalgic in a
weird way because i thought oh my gosh
that's where i slept that's where i live
except he did it way better and actually
built himself a shelter instead of me
just sitting there crying in the rain
but i think that the best part of
watching him on exile was knowing that
when i was there i got so much
personally out of the experience and to
see that rocks roy did too knowing that
his vision is declining and he was able
to really be present and enjoy the
fijian scenery it was honestly so
heartwarming and so touching to see
okay so of course there's no surprise
that rocks roy did exactly what you did
in season 41 and he smashed the
hourglass to change the course of the
game which in turn made the original
safe six play for individual immunity
yeah and although jonathan didn't win he
continues proven challenges and at camp
that he is in fact a powerhouse erica
how soon do you think this will start to
impact his game now that it's
individual it's so interesting because
jonathan still has no chill about how
strong he is he's still literally
carrying his team through the challenge
he's throwing a spear sorry he's
throwing a spear
casually at a stingray in the ocean and
easily someone like that gets high on
the threat list but i think that what
we're seeing now is at this point in
survivor what normally would be a threat
now people are keeping him around as a
shield so who knows maybe him being this
super strong guy is actually going to
keep him in the game a bit longer just
so people can keep the target on him and
not on themselves
now back to camp omar was really out
there making moves and trying like hard
to influence the vote despite being safe
and without a vote himself erica we need
to know your take on this
i think that this is a great survivor as
it's meant to be played classic survivor
where you know everybody's motivations
you know how to appeal to everybody
else's motivations and you can make
things done with your social skills and
your strategic skills and i think that
people who watch survivor you know love
these amulets and idols and all of these
powers and in this moment we have
someone like omar who doesn't even have
a vote which is the baseline power that
everybody else gets and he's really able
to influence the vote and make something
happen so i'm really excited to see this
play i'm hoping that omar can still
stay under the radar and not really take
a lot of black for it
and we can continue to see what else he
can pull out of his hat as we go on in
the game